So good to see you.
Welcome, glad you're here tonight.
Uh, digging deeper every week, these Wednesday nights
we're progressing quickly through this series.
It's almost shocking how fast we've gone.
This is our fifth, uh, of seven big rocks.
And then we're gonna take, uh, a week to look at, um,
as you watch the video, you see them put
in the smaller rocks.
Second, we'll talk a about one specifically,
and then, uh, allude to a few others.
And then we're gonna take two weeks at the end
to talk about some sand.
And so the, the last things, the,
the third level things you might say.
And so that's, that's coming,
but we're already that far into it.
So, um, it's gonna be, gonna be quick to get
through the end, but I, it's been fruitful for my soul.
Like I've said before, this has been a,
a challenging study in a good way,
and grown my soul and my spirit a lot.
So hopefully for us as a church as well.
So tonight we're gonna dig deeper into humanity
that, uh, that big rock.
We studied Sunday, and so I wanna pray for us.
We'll dive in. Lord, thank you again for tonight.
And, uh, as we've been praying these nights,
these Wednesday nights, that they would be edifying
to your church, to your people, uh, not just
for head knowledge, but
that we would understand a little bit better about
who you are, about what you've done,
who we are in light of that, so that we can know you
better and love you more deeply.
And then in light of your love for us,
we can love others more faithfully.
So, God, thank you for your word.
Thank you for the, uh, the, the depth of people
throughout the history of the church
that have studied these things well, that have,
have written full books on the subject we're gonna talk
about for a few minutes tonight.
Uh, just thank you for the work done,
and I pray that you'd now give us insight
and wisdom as I share a little bit as Steve comes
and shares a little bit with us as well,
as we answer questions and, and just humbly walk
before you gotta give us that humility
before you, that we don't have all the answers.
We, we don't know all you do, and you are the answer.
And so, Lord, I pray we,
we walk in humility in these moments.
Uh, but then we also look to you
in confidence in faith that you have
shown us enough about yourself.
As incomprehensible as you are, you've shown us enough
that we can know you intimately and love you
because you've loved us first, because thank you for that.
Show us tonight, uh, what you want us to,
to know a little better
and how we can then be doers of your word,
not heroes only in Jesus' name.
Amen. All right.
So the big rock was humanity, mankind, uh, the,
the common term in theological circles is man,
and, and so we, we tried to kinda hedge away from that
because we don't want to connote anything
but that This is about humans.
Uh, so humanity, you might see it in various books, humanity
or mankind or, or man.
What we mean is human beings, male
and female, as Genesis one talks about.
And, and the question I asked Sunday was,
why is this a foundational rock humanity?
I mean, it seems like kind of already inherently know.
Well, again, because we don't understand our
salvation rightly, if we don't understand
who we are in light of who God is, uh,
we don't understand our relationship with him.
In light of that, we don't then look in the right places for
life because we're
misunderstanding some things about ourselves.
And then we also treat each other wrongly
because we don't understand what value people have.
So this is why it's a big rock.
It affects salvation when we talk about these big rocks,
by the way, in many ways, we're talking salvific issues,
things that have to do with salvation, right?
Not, not what we'll get to later with the smaller rocks
and the sand, but like, these things matter forever
in our salvation relationship with God.
So that was the first question was then, who are we?
Yes, we need to know who we are. And talking about identity.
Genesis one, of course, God said,
let us make man in our image, in our likeness, um, male
and female, he created them.
So it was this picture that God created humans in his image,
male and female distinct.
Psalm eight was something I didn't quote, but,
but just listen to the, the picture Psalm eight creates
of this idea of, of image of God
and what he created in humans.
When I look at your heavens, Psalm eight, three,
when I look at your heavens, the work of your fingers,
the moon and the stars, which you've set in place,
like just the magnitude of creation, the beauty of creation.
Verse four, what is man that you are mindful of him
and the son of man that you care for him,
Psalmist is just stunned.
Look at the massive beauty and magnitude of creation.
And you think about us
and he says, why you have made him humans
a little lower than the heavenly beings,
meaning the angels not lower in value or class, but,
but literally lower in a sense that way
you've made him a little lower than the heavenly beings
and crowned him with glory
and honor, talking about humans crowned
with glory and honor.
You've given him dominion over the works of your hands.
You've put all things under his feet
that's referencing Genesis one.
So as humans, we are crowned.
It says, with glory and honor, what's the glory?
Well, it's not in ourselves.
The glory is that we bear the image of God.
Each one of us, every human who's ever existed
bears the image, the glorious image of God.
Now, we know that that's tainted because of sin.
We'll get to that in a second. But,
but humans still even in sin, bear the image of God.
And, and we, we look at people
and like, how is that the image of God?
No, there's just an inherent sense in our personhood.
The essence of who we are as humans bears the image of God,
even in our sinful state.
And one day we'll be perfected again to
perfectly represent the image of God as Jesus did.
But we're not there yet. Once did,
and we'll get to this again in a second,
once we did at one point Adam
and Eve sin, we're not one day we'll be again.
Okay? So what does it mean? Image of God?
Just as a reminder, the reflection, the image of
when you look at that, you see something about the source.
So when you look at humans, you see something about
who God is, his character, his personality,
his heart, his actions.
We can create in a sense,
but we can't create out of nothing like he did.
But when we put a couple things together
and make something new like Angie does
so well in the cafe like that, that's a creation.
It reflects God's creative heart
and his his heart that did out of nothing.
What we try to do with, with something, uh, his, his heart.
And we love people like he loved us, his personality,
you know, he's joy and,
and all of these things
that you can see in scripture, he, he is that.
And so our personalities reflect some of God.
Colossians one 15 though, says, Jesus is the image
of the invisible God.
We are some images of God, but he is the image perfectly.
So when we talk about us as images, what, what
that means again, is that we are
to reflect God to the world.
That's what we are responsible for.
So we can't treat people like their property or transactions
or, or less than in any way.
Every person from conception until
physical death is equally independently valuable in
who they are as a person, image bearer of God.
So we show respect, we show dignity.
Uh, doesn't mean we agree with everything everybody does,
but it just means we respect
and show the dignity that it is.
Everybody's valuable in that. So that's who we are.
But then the question is, why are we,
uh, we know who we are.
But now why? Of course that was
because we were created for the glory of God.
Everything, every person, everything exists for
the glory of God.
We are God's ambassadors to take that glory
to people around us.
Official representatives reflections to a foreign nation.
And then what went wrong, of course, was
that sin entered the world.
And, and so we have a problem there,
and I, I skipped this a little bit in James three on Sunday,
but it, it talked about in James three, verse six and seven
and eight, that the tongue stains the whole body.
Uh, it, it in sense it a microcosm
of our sinful state.
When you just see what comes out of our mouths,
it's 'cause it's in our hearts.
And it, it stains, it sets on fire the whole.
Um, and it talks about in scripture
that our words can justify us.
Doesn't mean we're made perfect by our words.
It just means that we confess Jesus's Lord with our mouths.
So we speak that word in our heart, cry,
but it says, our words can condemn us.
It says they're set on fire by hell,
by sin, they stain everything.
They set life on fire.
Uh, and as much as we wanna restrain it, as much pain
and sorrow that our words create, again, every kind of beast
and bird, reptile, sea creature can be tamed,
has been tamed, but no human being can tame the tongue.
It's a restless evil, full of deadly poison.
So we needed God to change our hearts,
give us new hearts that will speak differently.
But just becoming a Christian doesn't take away all
that poison that's in there.
Not in our hearts, God's new creation heart,
but in our flesh, what's remnant from
what we were born into, there's still this measure of sin
that that shows up because of that.
Now, the thing about it is the new heart
should restrain the tongue,
should restrain our sin.
We should be very different.
Now, we talked a lot about that Sunday,
but it's still gonna happen.
You know, you're still gonna say something you shouldn't say
to your kids, or you're gonna say, uh,
perpetuate gossip at work, or, or something like that.
It's, it's going to happen.
But as we grow into this image perfectly more every
day, it restrains it.
That's the grace of God in that.
So the solution is a new heart. Eel 36.
We talked a lot about that. Um, that's, that's that the,
the tongue is a fire picture.
And we need the Holy Spirit, the water, the living water
of Christ to come quench the fire that our tongues are,
that our sin is.
And so we need him to quench it first,
and then we need to soak in his living water.
It's what his word is for, it's
what his spirit is in us for.
Uh, if we allow our flesh to dominate,
we get Galatians five works of the flesh.
If we allow our spirit, his spirit to dominate,
we get the fruit of the spirit,
those things in Galatians five as well.
So we, we've looked at our,
our heart's kinda like a sponge, what we put in there.
It's what's gonna come out when it's squeezed.
So we need to be soaking in the word.
Now, the question, it was kind of alluded to last week,
David asked it, why did sin
happen in the first place?
God could've, could've stopped it.
Uh, then we wouldn't have gone through the trauma
and suffering and all the things that we have.
Well, the follow up question to that is then,
did God ordain sin?
Then? Like, did God create sin?
Well, we have to say no.
'cause James earlier says that,
that God cannot be tempted by evil.
So he can't sin in that sense.
But we could say that God ordained the whole, whole process
in such a way that he's not morally guilty for the sin.
But he has so ordained it that he would set it up like that
so that he receives even more glory
in saving sinners than he would by just creating a bunch
of robots that just obey him all the time and follow suit.
That's one way he could have gotten glory.
But, but the beauty of it is
that he gave us a measure of choice.
We'll talk about this Sunday,
and then a couple weeks later, a measure of free will there
to where we can choose.
Yet he also ordained the whole.
So that's a mind blowing concept.
We'll have to figure that one out. But the idea is he
ordained this process so that he could maximize the glory
through us as fallen creatures redeemed
into a relationship with him again,
where he took us from death, made us alive just like Jesus.
So there's a measure of God's glory that's heightened
by the fact that sin entered the world
and that we're all born into it.
So we'll get to probably some questions about that.
But, but let's think about this.
This, uh, original creation, original
creation of humans, the relationships that we have.
So typically, I I offhandedly said this Sunday,
whenever you have, most theologians would say
that there are three relationships we're created to have.
When you look at Genesis one and two, the way God made Adam
and Eve, there's three relationships.
The first is a relationship with nature, with creation,
that God gave them dominion over creation.
And still we have today, I'll get to that in a second.
So, relationship with nature, relationship with God,
that he's walking with them in the cool of the night
of the day, and then relationship with others, with people,
that those are the three relationships
we are created to have.
Now, each of these, I'm about to get to these stages,
affects the way that we handle those relationships.
So when you think about the original image of God, Adam
and Eve, their relationship with creation was perfect.
Their relationship with God was fully face-to-face their
relationship with nature or with, uh, with others.
No shame naked together, right? That was the original image.
Well, when sin entered the world,
there was a perverted image, then a tainted image,
where even those three relationships
were affected by that, right?
What happened in Genesis three?
He cursed the ground, which means work is hard.
So our relationship with nature is hard.
It's thorns, it's thistles, it's broke knee.
Like, it's these things that make life hard.
Our relationship with God was not face-to-face anymore.
In fact, he kicked him out
of his presence, out of the garden.
And we've been separated from him ever since.
In our sin, our relationship with others was broken.
They had to create things to hide from each other
and just in shame, they were not like they were before.
So the perverted image, you see,
even affects those relationships.
Then when Christ comes to restore, renew
the image in us.
Think of how those three relationships are changed again,
the relationship with nature.
Well, we now see that God has created this the way he has.
And one day we'll recreate this.
So it's actually something we wanna steward.
Well, it's not throwaway, even creation.
'cause God created it. Our relationship with God is new.
It's renewed where we now have him dwelling within
us by grace.
Our relationship with others has changed,
where we can now be kind and tenderhearted
and loving all of that.
You see how the renewed image now changes those three
relationships, and then one day, again,
perfected image when Jesus returns makes it all new.
Think of those three relationships again,
our relationship with nature.
New heavens and new earth. It's all good.
Again, perfect lying, lamb, laying down together,
our relationship with God, back, face
to face, our relationship with others.
Perfect. No shame, no sin.
So it, it's really interesting you think
of those three relationships in all
of those stages throughout history
and throughout our history as humans.
And so I, I alluded to this last week,
but I found it, I couldn't fit it in Sunday, but I found it.
It's similar to those four stages I just mentioned.
And this is from Augustine.
I couldn't recall where it was last week,
but he says the, there are four states,
and they correspond to the four states
of man in relation to sin.
So he is not talking necessarily about the relationships
with, it's kind of with God,
but not with nature, not with others, really.
Uh, but here's his four states.
Again, there's Latin terms for these.
I won't try to read those. But our original image,
our original state, Adam and Eve, they were able to sin
and they were able not to sin.
They had both abilities.
They were able not to sin,
and they were able to sin in our perverted
image after sin
after Genesis three,
humans then were not able not to sin.
So as hard as you and I try, we can't, not sin,
we don't want to in many ways,
but we, we just, it, it happens.
That's humans in our perverted image. Okay?
Well, then Christ comes, renews the image.
This is his third state. It is able now not to sin.
So there's a possibility now in us, with Christ in us,
the Holy Spirit's power that we can choose not to sin.
One Corinthians 10 13, no temptation is overtaken you,
except what is common to man.
God is faithful. He will not let you be tempted
beyond what you can bear.
But when you are tempted, he'll provide a way out
so you can stand up under it,
which means there's the possibility you have
when you're tempted by whatever fill in the blanket is
to not have to do it in your sin
before this perverted image, you are not able not to sin,
but now renewed, you are able not to sin again.
Well, then there's one more state, the perfected image,
the glorified state where we are unable to sin.
So you think about the end of the book, he says,
no more tears, no more pain, no more suffering,
no more sorrow, no more death.
All those former things that passed away included
no more sin, which means you
and I can't sin anymore, unable to sin.
So you see the state
before the fall able to sin and able not to sin
after the fall, not able not to sin.
We have to, that's what we are required to in a sense,
after Christ, able now not to sin.
And then glorified heavens, new heavens, new earth with him,
unable to sin at that place.
So it, it just helps me kind of understand a little bit
of this progression of humanity, of where we have come and,
and where we are right now.
So if you are a believer in Christ, you've been renewed,
the image of God is being renewed in you,
and one day it'll be perfect again.
But right now, you're in that renewed state
where you're able not to sin.
That gives me hope.
Like I, I remember a, a time
and in my life where it felt like I couldn't do
anything but fill in the blank.
Whatever was tempting me at the time,
because I'd never understood really what it meant
to live the power of God, of, of his spirit inside
with the renewed image of God
that I don't have to send anymore.
That now we're not saying you can be perfect
in this life, but we don't have to sin.
So to walk into a place of, of temptation, a moment
of temptation, and realize there's the ability
to overcome this right now.
Not in me, not in anything I have,
but in Christ, in me, the hope of glory.
Galatians two 20, I've been crucified with Christ.
I no longer live, but Christ lives in me.
The life I live in, the flesh.
I live by faith in the son of God who loved me
and gave himself up for me.
That's the power I have to not follow into that sin again.
So that's, I I wanted to dig into
that a little bit more than just brush over it on Sunday.
So this was a, a great time for that.
Steve, why don't you come on up here.
I wanna ask you a couple questions to help kind
of facilitate towards some, uh,
maybe further questions as we go forward.
I, I, I found this quote as he's coming up here, this quote
that when we think about, okay,
what does that renewed image look like?
What does it look like for me to live a life as a human
yet renewed, restored?
How do I know what to do? How do I know
what the right thing is to do?
Here's a quote. As a follower of Jesus, I want to learn
to live the life Jesus would live
if Jesus were living my life.
So I, as a pastor, I've gotten a lot
of questions from people who are kind of discerning, like,
what, what's my career path?
What should I, what should I do
with making a decision on this job or that job?
And how do I treat this person at work?
How do I, you know, so we get all kinds of questions.
That's a pretty simple, and it
goes with the what would Jesus do?
Bracelets, I always kind of mock those earlier in my life.
It's actually pretty good if this is what it is, right?
As a follower, Jesus, I wanna learn
to live the life Jesus would live if he was living my life,
which means every one of us is gonna have a bit
of a nuance there.
So I'm not in your workplace, you're not in her home,
you're, you're, you're in different family
background situations.
How would Jesus live this life?
If I'm in the image of God, he's the perfect image of God.
How would he live this? If he was me?
How would he live this out? Decide, act, think, uh, speak.
Just a helpful little thought.
I just found that as I thought it'd be helpful.
Okay, so Steve, I I already kind
of answered this a little bit, but talk about fallen man
still bearing the image of God.
How does that work? How, how does it look
whenever we look around, there's a mess
and people are, some are, some are really far.
Like we typically talk about like Hitler state.
Is he in the image of God, really?
I mean, then you got this,
this really good person down the street from me in my
neighborhood, not a believer,
but they're a good dude, right?
He's a good guy, good American citizen.
Yeah, of course he's bearing the image of God.
But in all of us, we're all fallen.
So does fallen man still bear the image of God?
And how does that even work out?
They don't let me up here very often.
Um, and I've got all my resources here,
and, um, uh, I, I really was thinking about this image
of God and the idea that, um,
um, what does that mean?
Is it, is it a physical image?
I mean, I don't look like God.
Um, but John has talked about, about the,
the characteristics and things that we think about.
And, um, uh, I'm thinking that, uh,
I remember a story, and I, I want to answer the question,
but I remember that often in growing up, um,
people would say, you remind me a lot of your dad,
or You're a spitting image of your dad.
We had the same haircut.
And, uh, my father's gone on to be with the Lord.
And, uh, he was, um, baldheaded and he was a coach.
And, um, I didn't want to be a coach
because I didn't want to follow exactly what he did.
But there were some, there are many aspects of his character
that I wanted to follow, and I, and I appreciated that,
and I learned from him.
So, when I think about the image of God and,
and how that is, man, I, uh, tied to that, I'm, I'm,
there are certain things that, uh, that, that are tied to
that opportunity to be, to learn from
what God has in our lives
and how He, he tells us how to live our lives.
Uh, but I'm not God. I don't, I'm going to make mistakes.
I am a fallen man.
Um, but yet I, I'm not without hope.
Um, and I, uh, I, I can't, uh, think enough about, um,
how important it is to remember, uh, that, uh,
I am in the image of God,
and that that's, uh, not something that, uh, uh,
is not without hope
and not without, uh, um, a future promise
and a future goal and eternity.
Uh, I I made myself some notes about some things that, uh,
um, uh, image
and, uh, I'm still going to be a person that, uh, is, is
going to sin.
Um, and,
but John made the point just a minute ago about the fact
that you can walk yourself into a situation
and you can say, okay, what am I gonna do?
Am I going to, what would would Jesus do?
But now to know that through the, the power
of the Holy Spirit, uh, I have the ability to, through
the Holy Spirit, to, to make the right decision
and turn away from that sin.
Um, and I think that's, um, something that I, I I need
to continually remember
and, uh, uh, practice in my own life.
Um, so that's kinda the things that I think about, uh,
with regard to the image of God
and how we look at that in our own lives.
Um, I'm not sure that, uh,
fallen man still bears the image of God.
Um, but it's, it's, it's, it's such that, um,
I just wanna make sure I remember
that image is not the exact reflection.
And then we're not talking about a physical image.
We're talking about characters and qualities
and ingredients that make up so much, uh, in our own lives
and how we want to try to improve, uh, constantly,
constantly wanting to improve. So,
Yeah. And, and there's a measure
of what we call common grace
in people too.
Um, I can't remember exactly what it said,
but we're,
what common grace does, which I would say kinda the image
of God does, is that we're not all as bad as we could be.
Hmm. Uh,
and that's God's restraint of things, which you look at.
Again, typical example, you look at Hitler like,
did he restrain Hitler?
He could have done more. I mean that as bad as it was.
And so there's a measure of that image of God
that there's a bit of restraint in that,
and that's com common grace kind of blended together there.
But, but yeah.
So there's a picture of God in the image, all of
Us Yeah. Reading on it
says, this means that man is like God
and represents God.
Man's offspring is made in his image and likeness
after the fall, man is still in God's image.
Genesis nine, six James three nine.
Though it is distorted through Christ, the full image
of God is being renewed in us through Christ.
Um, and when he appears one John three, two,
we shall be like him. Yeah.
Yeah. That perfected image again, right? Yeah. All right.
So this, this is a tough one,
and I wrestled with this, I alluded to it Sunday, about
how can we be held liable or guilty for Adam's sin.
We weren't there. Like, we weren't in the garden.
We didn't eat the fruit. How, how can we be born into sin?
That wasn't our fault. I mean,
that's just the typical comments
that people will make in light of that.
So how, why am I guilty because of Adam's sin
Number a couple years ago, uh, when I was in the, uh,
elder mentoring process, uh, we had the privilege of going
through a series of questions, um,
and theological questions, um, similar questions to what was
I had the experience in
and dealing with when I became going
through the be a deacon.
But anyway, the question was, uh,
what are the results of Adam's sin?
And so I wrote and,
and quoted, uh, God's word in Romans chapter five, verse 12,
due to Adam's sin, sin entered the human race,
therefore, just as sin came into the world through one man
and death through sin.
And so death spread to all men,
because all sinned for sin indeed was in the world
before the law was given.
But sin is not counted where there is no law
yet death reigned from Adam to Moses,
even over those whose sinning was not like the transgression
of Adam, who was the type of the one who was to come.
But the free gift does not like the trespass were
if many died through one man's trespasses,
much more have the grace of God
and the free gift by the grace of that one man,
Jesus Christ, abounded for many.
And the free gift is not like the result of
that one man's sin.
So Romans chapter five, beginning with verse 12, um,
tells us clearly that the Bible, uh, says
that sin entered the world through one man.
Uh, and it was through Adam that sin entered.
And, uh, we are born, we were, we are born physically alive,
but spiritually dead.
And, uh, it may not seem fair to be saddled
with Adam sin nature, but it's certainly consistent
with other aspects of, of human humanity.
We inherit some physical characteristics such as eye color
and hairstyle from my dad,
but we also inherit some spiritual characteristics.
Um, and so in the same way having to send nature
is in a sense a matter of spiritual genetics.
Uh, it's just a natural part of life.
Um, however, the Bible says that, uh, uh, you know,
that that's where we are.
Um, and, uh, there's discussion about imputed sin
and personal sin.
Uh, imputed sin is from Adam
and credit to us, uh, Romans five 18.
Uh, and then, uh, we sin every day.
Uh, we have a sin nature, and therefore we will sin.
Ephesians two, three says, among whom we all once lived,
and the passions of our flesh carrying out the desires
of the body and the mind,
and we're by nature, children are worth
like the rest of mankind.
But for Jesus, uh, in our lives
and salvation, uh, that gets us, uh, where we need to be.
And that's how I, fairness issue is,
doesn't seem fair,
but boy, God's grace is awesome.
Yeah. And, and the reality,
I I just quickly said this Sunday,
the reality is if we don't believe that, if we kind
of deny the reality, like, wow, we, Adam stood in
for us, that's not fair.
Well, Christ stood in for us,
so we better believe that's fair.
It just works the other way too.
And it says it in Romans five, that idea of Christ is,
or Adam was our head in a sense, like the first
in order in line.
Well, Christ is the new head of the church,
and his sacrifice counts for us imputes to us
where Adam imputed sin to us
Christ imputes righteousness to us.
It's the, the double imputation on, uh,
the cross it talks about in a lot of books.
But we,
our sin was imputed onto Christ,
and Christ's righteousness was imputed onto us in
that transaction on the cross.
So just like Adam sinned made us guilty,
Christ righteous makes us righteous.
And so we have to, we have to tie those two together.
And yeah, it might not seem fair,
but I read this, uh, I couldn't find it now.
I just was skimming so many things.
I read this today, and they were probably a little facetious
in saying, but like,
do we really think we would've made a different
decision in the garden?
Whether it was that one moment or some other moment?
I, that's a pretty arrogant statement for us to make,
that I wouldn't have fallen.
Yeah. I, I wouldn't have done that. I,
Uh, that's, that's tenuous to say that, right?
Um, because we all have that same nature that Adam had.
We don't know what it's like to be Adam,
where we're able not to sin,
but if we were created in that moment, still,
you see the same thing. Yeah.
And I red here, but here's the good news.
God loves sinners. In fact, he's acted
to overcome our sin nature by sending Jesus to pay
for our sins once and pay for our sins,
and offer us his righteousness.
First Peter two, uh, 24,
he himself bore our sins in his body on the tree
that we might die to sin
and live to righteousness by his wounds,
you have been healed.
Yeah. So that's, that gives me great comfort. Yeah.
Okay. I wanna make one more comment
and then we'll open it up for questions.
Uh, Genesis 1 27 says, male and female, he created them.
So mankind, humans were created male and female.
He created 'em, he created other, other animals, male
and female as well, 'cause they could reproduce.
But male and female, he created them humans.
If there's anything being confused in our world right now,
that's one of the big ones, right?
We, we believe those
male female standards are
static, immutable, unchangeable,
that at the essence of each person, whether they're a man
or a woman, they're male or female.
And so we believe that as a church, uh, we will stand on
that as a church.
In saying that, though, with the confusion that's out there,
we must stand on it.
Teach our children, teach our teens,
teach ourselves what that means.
But with the confusion that's out there, knowing
that each one of those people that you might get so angry at
that I might think is crazy, for whatever reason,
that's also an image barrier of God.
So, yes, disagree, yes, we can hold to our standards,
we can hold to our beliefs about that, and we should,
because it's very clear.
But in our reaction to somebody who's
so vitriolic about that, passionate about that
we treat them as an image bearer of God
and love them, speak truth in love.
But we, we hope that the dignity you show to someone,
rather than ranting, raving Facebook comments,
honking horns, throwing stuff, whatever it is
that's happened, sadly,
what if we could be different in our disagreement?
The world has a, a tough time figuring out
that you can disagree and still love someone.
It's possible. But in our disagreement, we still love them.
Treat them with the dignity that an image bearer
of God deserves.
Because there is something under the surface there
probably a lot of background and baggage and history
and things that if you just sit
and get curious about their life, something might show up
that that would be a way you can apply the gospel.
S solve the balm of the soul to their lives.
So yes, we can hold fast to our, to our beliefs,
and we can love those people that don't believe that,
because that's an image bearer of God.
So that's, that's why this humanity stuff matters.
Because it, it does affect the way we treat people.
And I put it in my email today to the church that, you know,
there's all kinds of ways that the least of these
that are often kicked to the side are not image bearers
of God are forgotten.
How about the church? We believe that
that special needs child is an image bearer of God.
Let's care for them. Let's love them, their families.
Let's serve them. Uh, the, the prisoner, the outcast,
the widow, the orphan.
All these things that are so often kicked
to the side, the single mom.
Like, just say, no, no, you don't fit here.
No, listen, you are loved here.
'cause you're an image bearer of God.
How different that is to the world
who judges based on value, we say, you're all valuable.
Come on, God loves you. We love you.
Let's treat each other like that.
That's what the image that the humanity doctrine leads us
to in part that image bearer of God.
Okay? So questions. You would have got the mics up here.
Steve will answer for you.
And then, uh, we'll go that directions.
Hi. Mm-Hmm. Okay.
So, um,
I was raised in very small Southern Baptist churches where
I think the theology was probably 95% correct.
But I've spent my adult life weeding through the other 5%
to try to make sure that
I'm seeing it correctly.
Um, so every once in a while something is said that kind
of pricks back at those things.
Um, some of the fire and brimstone stuff that I was taught.
And you said something on Sunday
that stopped me for a second.
And I just was wondering if you could clarify, um,
and I I'm gonna misquote it, I'm sorry.
But it was something about how
there's a record of the things we say
that will be held accountable for.
And having grown up being taught that you'd have the movie
of your life played, you know, at the gates of heaven.
I was just wondering if you could kind of clarify
what that looks like for a believer.
Hmm.
That's good. That's a good question.
And I'm so thankful that, uh, you
and others would be wrestling with some of those things
that we should be wrestling with.
So praise the Lord for that. I was
trying to find where it is.
Uh, yeah, Matthew 1236.
So Jesus is saying either, either make the tree good
and it's fruit good, or make the tree bad.
And it's fruit bad for the tree is known by its fruit.
You brood of vipers.
How can you speak good when you are evil?
For outta the abundance of the heart, the mouth speaks,
the good person out of his good treasure brings forth good.
The evil person out of his evil treasure brings forth evil.
I tell you, on the day of judgment, people will give account
for every careless word they speak for.
By your words, you'll be justified.
And by your words, you'll be condemned.
So that's the the verse that I was quoting there.
And it's, it's saying that God's keeping a record
of every word we say, every tweet, every Facebook posts,
and everything that we ever would verbalize or t
or type in that sense.
So what does Jesus mean when he says, on the day
of judgment, people will give a count?
Is it the, the story, the video
of which I would guarantee most of us have heard
that at some point in our lives in church, right?
The movie's gonna play and you're gonna sit there and watch.
That's a long movie, by the way.
Um, you know, watch everything,
and you're gonna feel so guilty
and ashamed over all those things you did.
And now this is where we get into
some of the rewards
and not rewards for Christians,
that there's judgment seats, plural.
Uh, there's the judgment seat that will be
for the, the goats
and sheep, the, you might say, believers,
non-believers judgment seat, so to speak.
Uh, Jesus talks about, what did you do with me
while you were here away from me?
I never knew you. That's Matthew seven.
So there's that judgment seat.
But then there's also a judgment seat
of rewards for believers.
Now, let me just caveat all this.
The rewards he's talking about is not like we're gonna have
different classes of heaven.
'cause the rewards you get are simply
that you're gonna cast at his feet to worship
and praise God, and you'll just get
a little bit more than somebody else.
But it's not like you're gonna feel if,
if you read the Bible at the end, it says,
there's no more tears, no more shame, no pain,
no more sin, those kind of things.
So we're not saying you're going to feel in a sense,
less than because it,
it's the Lord Jesus is right in front of you.
So you won't feel less than.
But it talks about it in such a way,
and this is even getting to like Hebrews six,
the warning passages.
Can you lose your salvation?
Some of these things, uh, there's a measure of warning there
that's saying, if you could, this is
what it would look like for you to do that.
But since you can't, you don't have to worry
that you're going to it.
It's almost like a hypothetical.
It's not a hypothetical, it's a conditional statement
that assumes it's not true.
There's structures of Greek that that does that
it assumes it to be true at times
and assumes it to be not true at times.
But it still says it as like possibility.
Like, if you could lose your salvation,
this is what it would look like.
But you, you can't.
So I think there's some of that playing into this.
He's talking to
Pharisees, non-believers.
So people will give account for every careless word.
They speak by your words. You'll be justified by your words.
You'll be condemned. Well, are words
that justify us or what?
I spoke everything perfectly throughout all my history.
They play that video and I'm all good.
We're all, we're all done. Nobody does that.
So by your words, you're justified. What are the words?
Confess with your mouth, Jesus' Lord, you'll be saved.
You're justified by that.
You're condemned by your words and everything else.
He's just talking about what they were saying in the moment.
That was the Pharisees, uh, that they were,
it was a demon oppressed man.
And the people were amazed.
And they're, they're saying things.
The Pharisees heard it,
and they said, it's only by alible the prince of demons
that this man casts out demons.
He knew what they were saying even in their minds.
So he's, it's the context that he's,
whatever he was talking about could have been
something different if it was different context.
But he's talking about their words. So he's using
that as the illustration.
Your hearts are wicked.
So that's why you're saying this thing that I'm,
I'm the king of demons, really.
It's because that's in your heart.
So by your words, you're condemned, by your actions,
your lust, you're stealing your,
all these things you're condemned to, just happens
to be in this context, the words.
So he's talking to unbelievers in that moment.
So we have to remember that for that season.
But we can't also get away from these rewards.
He talks about in, uh, where is that First Corinthians?
No, second Corinthians. I dunno.
You have to find it somewhere, um, where
there's the foundation of Christ.
And then it asks, what are you building off that foundation
with, are you building with wood, hay,
and stubble things that are gonna burn up in the end?
Or are you building with gold
and silver and precious stones?
Not literally building a house.
We're not building a heavenly house ourselves.
But what that's talking about is
off the foundation of Christ.
What are we building our lives with, with our way?
We say things, the way we spend our money, the way we
treat our kids, the way we work
with neighbors, like all of that.
Those are all actions that build a house in a sense.
And the judgment, so to speak,
is gonna burn away all the stuff that was not
of God, what's left.
That's then what you'll be rewarded, quote unquote for.
So we shouldn't as believers have to fear that
like an unbeliever would fear the judgment seat
where you will be cast away from God forever,
because that's already been paid for on the cross for us.
We're not there anymore. We're not at this.
Well, you're gonna be justified
or condemned by your words that Jesus
would say to these Pharisees.
We're not there anymore as believers, we're past that.
We're on the justified side already.
So we're now in this state of, this is not a
judgment in a negative sense.
This is a judgment to burn
away all the stuff that's not of me.
And I'm gonna give you my presence forever.
And you get to worship with the stuff that you,
that's left over, you get to worship.
So there shouldn't be a measure of fear.
'cause that's how it's often used,
is you're gonna play this movie up there, you better be.
But, but what kind of gospel is that?
If you play this movie and it,
it's like the scale's balance in your favor based on
how well that movie went
or didn't like, that's not the gospel that is works.
And he balance the scale and makes sure,
and it's just a fear-based inducement of good works.
And those don't save us.
So already saved, already justified
by the words of my mouth.
Confess with your mouth, Jesus' Lord,
my life then is an ambassador, powered by the Holy Spirit so
that I can build a house on the foundation
of Christ that's gonna last.
And he's going to be glorified by that.
And then it's gonna, it's gonna be forever
eternal worship of God.
So we should not fear those kind of things.
And that's an untangling for a lot of us.
I, I felt that too.
Um, just remember those two separate
judgements that are coming.
We're not in this one anymore if we're in Christ.
So no more fear, no more shame in that. Great question.
Great. Anything to add Steve to that? Okay. Don't think so.
I talk too much. Um, or anybody else? What other questions?
I guess I'd just, uh, just start contemplating this when
you said it, but, uh, in the last, uh,
phase when we go to the new heavens and new Earth, right?
Do we, I guess we lose that ability to send,
um, we lose free choice.
We kind of become that robot that people will ask, you know,
why didn't he just create us as robots?
I don't know. That's just kind of what I just
started, started thinking about.
Yeah. Yeah. Good question. Good question.
Um, do we lose the ability to choose
after we're glorified?
I think when you look at the trajectory of
creation to new creation, there's
so many parallels between those two things.
The garden itself is in a sense, remade the tree
of life is there.
So that, that's what's cool about this.
I could go on a tangent about this.
Um, two weeks from now, we'll do the last things.
That's our, one of our big rocks,
talk about heaven, things like that.
But the tree of life that they were eating from
that kept them alive,
they would've literally lived forever in the garden, created
to they sinned.
God chose to kick them out of the garden
because he didn't want him to eat the tree of life anymore.
So they died, then he could resurrect them, right?
So that, it's just never thought about that
for that's pretty cool.
What's gonna happen in the new heavens new Earth?
That tree of life shows back up to
where we can eat from the tree of life and live forever.
But the parallels between the two things,
if we're created the image of God with the choice so
to speak, then I believe,
and this, I don't know, I'd have to ask Randy Alcorn
who wrote the book on heaven, but I think
there would be a measure of we're unable to sin.
Not because we're robots, but
because we have been made new fully our flesh,
which is the thing that keeps us here,
still tempted, still sinning.
We have a new creation spirit,
but our flesh is still broken.
So we're still tempted by sin.
Well, Jesus is the perfect image of God.
So our bodies will be like his was
after his resurrection.
We've been resurrected too. He's the first fruits of that.
So in a way, we'll have the same ability.
Jesus had not to unable to sin in that moment.
There'll be no temptation too.
So we can't even choose something
that would lead us towards sin.
Uh, but, but we also still have to have this ability to say
to to God, Lord,
you are, you are worthy.
And that's not just a, a robot-like thing.
It's because even though we have new bodies, we still,
I, again, speculation,
but I, I still think we'll have a recollection of
how God has worked in our history, our lives.
We won't be burdened by the negative.
We won't be burdened by the sin,
the temptation, the trauma, the suffering.
What we'll only be able to see with sanctified,
glorified eyes is what God wanted us to see
as he was working it out.
You know? So the difficult story that
many have walked through to watch from that side of it
to see how God, and that's just glory to him.
That's just worship for what he's done
to sustain you through this.
And how that's built everybody else's faith
as we watch you do that, right?
So that's the beauty of, I won't forget,
but I won't remember that series
of temptations that I gave into.
I won't remember. It won't do that.
All I remember is the blood of Christ.
And I'll remember what he was doing in the middle
of the things that has to have some sense of agency,
some sense of choice in that I'm not a robot at that point.
'cause Jesus wasn't after his resurrection.
I don't think we would be either.
So parallels between Genesis one
and Revelation 22, there's a lot
that you can learn as you tie those together.
I was just thinking about, Pick up your
mic. There you go.
I was just thinking about Brandon, you talk about, uh,
when I think about heaven,
we all have our own thoughts, I guess.
But for forever, my number one thought about,
uh, when I go to heaven, who am I gonna see?
Who am I gonna recognize
and who's the first person I'm gonna interact with?
So I never think about my mind being wiped clean
or my memories are gonna be erased.
And it's just, but I don't know.
Uh, but I look forward to obviously that.
And I think about, uh, you know, my mother, my dad,
my grandmother, all those types of things I think about.
I wanna see them. But is that even going to be
important in heaven?
And I'm not being, um, negative, I'm just, is
that gonna be important, uh, in eternity?
Um, I don't know.
That's just, that's kind of what I think about One
of the first things I think about heaven. So
Yeah, I mean, when the glorified Jesus
standing right in front of you, it's like,
will I really care about much else at that moment?
I don't. So we'll have to see.
But yeah, good question though. Yeah, thank you.
Could I add something to that? Yeah.
I'm thinking about this as a process.
God allows us to, uh, encounter certain things
during our life as Christians in order to grow us
for his purposes and to mature us.
And as I understand sanctification
and glorification, glorification is the point
at which we reach full maturity in Christ.
And I don't think we'll really want to choose
things that would dishonor him when we reach
that full glorification.
I'll give you an example of something.
Um, my brother and brother passed away.
My oldest brother passed away last January,
and it was very sudden, it was unexpected.
But Ron had been a follower of Christ for a long time,
and because of that, um, he,
he had fallen off of a ladder, hit his head,
and God gave me a real peace,
a about Ron being in the presence of God
before he hit the ground, being in the presence of Christ,
his savior, whom he dearly loved.
And all I could think about in those four days
where they tried to bring him back
and tried various medical approaches was
he's in the presence
of Christ, his savior.
What an awesome thing.
Why would he wanna come back to this world?
It gave me so much peace
and so much joy to just think
about him being in Christ presence.
And if we understand what it's like to be with Christ,
with that all encompassing love
and that all encompassing peace, I don't think we'll want
to choose something other than
that would bring him glory. Yeah.
Yeah. That's, thanks Jan. Thank you.
That, that reminds me.
We, you remember we talked about a couple weeks ago, the,
the incarnation, God, the Son, to nature's one person,
human nature, divine nature,
that the human nature was fully submitted in every moment,
every way perfectly to the divine nature.
Divine will human will submitted to the divine will.
So that was part of the question, could Jesus have sinned?
Well, yes but no. Right?
He's human, but, but his human will was fully submitted.
That's where we're gonna be.
Like Janie was saying, that's where we're gonna be.
Someday we'll have a renewed nature
in our humanness to where we'll want nothing
but to obey and worship and praise,
and there's no way out of
that good, the best sense of that word.
Good. You got anything else? I don't know if it needs
No, I was just gonna say that, um,
you're probably gonna talk about some
resources and things like that.
Um, a little booklet called The Westminster Shorter Cat
Chim, I don't think I pronounce it.
Catechism This, a little booklet, uh,
very interesting, very good to read.
And this little short form I would
encourage you to get, get your copy.
Um, my daughter gave me this the other day,
I mean, a couple years ago.
And, um, just something to put in my pocket.
So something I would encourage,
And it's q and a format.
Yeah, right? They ask a question
and then answer it with scriptures.
And so it's sort of a easy way
to remember things kinda like we do in q and a.
We've got some of the resources down here, uh,
one about being created in God's image,
another one about a theology of sin.
I mean, just thick book on sin.
It's like, that's a depressing read,
but it's really important, right?
You see why it's important.
And then a book I, I had forgotten I had it,
and I, I picked it up the other day.
It's called Urban Legends of Theology,
40 Common Misconceptions.
And so there's some interesting questions in there.
I don't, I haven't read it all, so I'm not gonna vouch
for everything in there that we're on board with.
But, uh, it, it really just pushes on some of the stuff
that we tend to believe just by default.
Some of this stuff was Elizabeth was asking earlier
that we just grew up with,
and we just never even questioned, never thought about it.
Like, God won't give me more than I can handle.
That's not true. He's always gonna give you more than you
can handle so that you lean on him.
It's okay. It, it's okay
that you have more than you can handle
because he's the one who's strong.
I boast about my weaknesses, as Paul says second Ians 12.
'cause in my weakness, he's made strong.
So that's one of 'em.
I I know that's in there, just these urban legends,
you know, that phrase, but just misconceptions.
So that might be a helpful tool just to get you
to think differently about some
of the things you grew up hearing, maybe you
even believe and hold.
Now, nothing wrong with that,
but we want to correct things
as we can in our own hearts and minds.
So come take a look at those if you want to later.
Um, but yeah, good stuff. Thank you again.
These, these are fun. Uh, just a sweet time to,
to get together and talk theology
and see how God wants to change us in.
So Aaron Ferguson is preaching this Sunday.
He's preaching on salvation, the big rock of salvation.
So basically just the gospel, Ephesians two.
Uh, so pray for Aaron.
Uh, I'm getting away with my wife for a little bit.
Pretty tired. So we're excited to get away.
But, um, yeah, so pray for Aaron.
Excited there. You good?
I was gonna pray whenever you're Ready. You
picked up your bike. I was
like, you got something else?
Okay. And I was gonna have you pray, so Perfect.
Awesome, awesome. Thank you.
Heavenly Father. We're so grateful for the privilege
and the freedom that we have together, together tonight, um,
to share and to talk
and to, uh, study your word.
Um, we're thankful for that freedom that we have.
And Lord, I pray now
for each person gathered together this evening.
I pray for their individual concerns and needs
and, uh, for their health, uh, for things
that are on their heart, uh, things
that might be troubling them.
Uh, Lord, I pray for your comfort for each one of them.
Uh, I pray for healing for those that are, that are ill.
Uh, I thank you for the good news of the gospel,
Lord Jesus Christ.
Lord, I thank you for John as he leads us, as he spends
so much time and prepare in preparation.
Uh, Lord, I pray for healing for him,
and I pray that, uh, you'll be with Brother Aaron as he, uh,
leads us and, and teaches us this coming Sunday.
Lord, I pray that you'll watch over each one of us
as we leave this place this evening.
I pray that For, uh, good evening of rest.
And, uh, Lord, I thank you for each person here.
Uh, how we love each, the opportunity to,
to serve together and to honor you.
And Lord, we give you all the glory. Amen.
Amen. Amen.